welcome back I'm not going to actually
do a couple more rates of change
problems but I think the first one I did
was probably a little bit more
complicated than I wanted and and it
actually the hard part was actually the
geometry not the calculus so let's just
say I drop a rock into a pond and it has
a ripple and the ripple spreads out
it'll probably have multiple ripples but
let's just say we focus on one ripple
and the ripple is spreading out so let's
say so let me draw this is where I drop
the rock
right and then this is a ripple in the
pond it would be an actual circle which
isn't what I drew but close enough okay
so let's say that the ripple so let me
say that let's call our our is not for a
ripple R is the distance that the ripple
is from the center from where I where it
started from the get-go right and and
it's it's not by chance that that's also
for radius so let's say that the the
ripple is moving out at 2 meters per
second so the rate at which R is
changing with respect to T is 2 meters
per second and what I want to know is
what is the rate at which the area the
area of this of that's kind of included
by this by this ripple right what is it
this entire area how fast is that
changing with respect to time when the
ripple is let's say 3 meters from from
the center when the ripple is equal to 3
meters well do we know any any relation
between the area of of this of the
circle essentially and the distance of
the ripple or or the radius well yes we
do area is equal to PI R squared and so
we want to figure out the rate which
area changes with respect to time so
what is the chain rule tell us the chain
rule tells us that the rate at which a
changes with respect to T is equal to
the rate at which a chain
with respect to R times the rate at
which R changes with respect to T well
we already know this piece right we
already know the rate at which R is
changing with respect to time that's
right here so we're really all we have
to do it to figure out the the rate at
which a is changing with respect to time
right that's this one right here if you
just figure out the rate at which a
changes with respect to R all right well
that's just the derivative the
derivative with respect to R so we just
say the derivative with respect to R do
it off both sides of a equals the
derivative with respect to R of PI R
squared so we get da d R is equal to
what's the dirt with respect to R here
well that's easy just 2 times pi two
times PI R to the 1 so we'll just leave
it there so that's pretty interesting
by itself that the rate at which the the
derivative of the area formula really is
1 this this this formula by itself looks
looks interesting right that's a former
for the circumference of a circle so the
derivative of an area of a circle with
respect to the radius is a circumference
that that is mod Li fascinating it's
something even more interesting is well
think about what figure out what the
what the integral is of figure out the
antiderivative is of the area and
compare that to the volume of a sphere
if we can look it up on Wikipedia or
something and and you can even look and
compare that to the surface area of the
sphere and just keep picking derivatives
and integrals and and and and there'll
be some pretty interesting relationships
but anyway back to the problem not not
to go on on to to pharma tangent so we
figured out the rate which changes with
respect to R so going back to our
original thing we now know that the rate
at which a changes with respect to T is
equal to the rate at which a changes
with respect to R well that's just right
here right the rate at which a changes
respect to R well that's just 2 pi
our times the rate at which our is
changing with respect to T right well
the rate which are changing for us to
use just right here right two meters per
second we figure that out so 2 PI R
times 2 and I'm actually a week well I
want to include the unit's because that
might confuse you right now so the ridge
which a is change with respect to T is 2
PI R times 2 well are we done yet well
no because we haven't substituted yet
for R so what is R well we know R is 3
is 3 meters so da DT is equal to 2 times
pi times 3 times 2 so what is that 2
times 3 is 6 times 2 is 12 12 PI and
it's meters squared per second right
because it's the rate at which area
square meters is changing with respect
to time and if we multiply out the units
we would have gotten the same thing
right here so in the next video I'm
going to do a slightly harder rate of
change problems just so that you know
you see that it doesn't only apply it up
kind of purely geometric things it
applies to pretty much anything that you
can find a relationship between two
values see in the next module